today's topic the Wrights now we've
talked about these quite often they've
been spreading they're still spreading
they're going larger and larger and
people want to hear our thoughts and so
I've taken a couple days to process I'm
not going to sit here and tell you that
I think it's good that mom-and-pop shops
are burning they're being finalized that
things are being looted there's no part
of me that's ever gonna say that there's
no part of me that's gonna get mad at
someone protecting their their place of
business from a looter you got to do
that you got to do what you got to do
I'm not mad at that but when you come to
me and you say I can't believe that
they're breaking buildings and they're
setting things on fire
what do you expect what conflict do you
know that has zero collateral damage
Americans go to foreign countries and
kill millions of people
as part of collateral damage and it's
inevitable every conflict that's ever
existed on this planet has had
sacrifices and collateral damage it
doesn't make me feel good I don't think
it's okay the same way you shouldn't
think it's okay that millions of Gammy's
and Rockies died as a result of war that
so many people during World War two were
raped and pillaged as a result of that
conflict collateral damage is inevitable
but I do find it quite distasteful that
people are so outspoken about brick and
mortar being destroyed people's
livelihoods being destroyed but when
people are stripped of their most
fundamental right which is their life so
many of you are quiet and the reason and
because you're quiet that's the reason
why people write because people are
silent on what matters that's why
they're writing you know rights are not
the voice of people who want to take
advantage of things they're the voice of
people who feel unhurt and so when
people are frustrated with decades and
decades and decades of brutality and
they come to this point and then you
just be like well they're charged jord
floor it's not about George Floyd
anymore it's gotten to be about
everything that's come before a history
of oppression and if you don't take the
time to acknowledge it then you can't
participate in this conversation in a
meaningful way that's why I was
disappointed when Trump got out there
he's like well these thugs
if they start lured we start shooting
what kind of leadership qualities that
when you lack the empathy to understand
why they're so angry of course they're
not going to listen to your pleas to
stay calm you
watson you made them you dehumanize them
and you and I and it frustrates me as I
sit here because people have so much to
say but they're not willing to listen
everyone wants to open their mouth
everyone wants to flap their gums they
want to type real fast and be like you
guys are wrong you should never but why
are they there everyone wants to treat
the symptom which are the rights but
never wants to deal address the the
illness the problem that we have here
these are there no black people think
specific not anymore if you look at
who's writing it's just young people of
all different races and colors yeah
because they're affected - they're
affected - grandi it's not that
segregated as you think right and so
because this is such a multicultural
country these people are living with
people from different communities they
feel their friends suffering they evoke
the other community suffering and so
they're in there with them it's not a
black and white thing no more so I would
just take time for people to try to
understand you know just so quick know
these videos these topics that were
covering they're gonna be demonetised
and when they get Deamonte eyes that
means it's harder for people to view
them because YouTube the algorithm
effects it differently so if you want to
be able to push this message out to more
people you want more people to see the
discussion please start the video hit
the like button make sure that everyone
can see this so that we can spread this
far and wide leave a comment all that
good stuff all right and if you're not
already subscribed in you're just
watching hit that subscribe button you
know hit that Bell so you can catch
these videos proper and not want to
support more you know there's always a
patreon as always the podcast you know
watch as well and it bothers me that you
paint everyone with such a broad brush
they're all looters really is that what
you think when you look at all the
footage of all the peaceful protests
people laying down calmly and just
trying to emulate George Floyd's last
moments do you think that they're the
same as looters when you come at this
with a lack of nuance and you just
scream you're just adding noise you're
not saying anything of substance so you
can choose to be empathetic and try to
understand so that you can see what's
happening for what it is or you can just
look at it from the lens that you've
been looking at it but I can see both
sides I can understand why you wouldn't
want the mom and pop shots to burn down
and I could also see why they're rioting
but the reality is until you address why
they're riding those shops will burn and
I it's inevitable that that's the only
two words I have it's inevitable so
people always bring up
why don't you guys do things like Martin
Luther King jr. keep in mind Maya
thinking jr. was assassinated for what
and when when when when did we see
rights as big as this right after he was
assassinated you know there's this idea
that's permeating that you have to
protest peacefully and that's how things
get done if the inception of this very
country is a built off of violence it's
built off of Rights it's built off of
revolution when Americans existed here
under British colony rule and they saw
injustice and they didn't like the way
things went
what did they do they ride they read
started their revolution it was about to
happen if someone that whispered is not
heard he's gonna start talking if he's
talking he's not heard he's gonna start
screaming if he's not hurt he's gonna
start punching if he's not hurt
he's gonna start breaking stuff if he's
not heard he's gonna start hurting if
he's not heard then and that's kalise
back in LA when there's something that
happened back then with the police and
we know the LA police is renowned for
that you know when it happened in LA was
one thing when people were watching
right and it was still not and now it's
happening again and the problem with the
police and I had with the police is that
they often don't do this P escalate
stuff they don't and that's what
happened so you see a public outrage of
the Pope you see the public outrage and
people are in the street and the
response of the police is what rubber
bullets so you create outrage on top of
outrage if I put oil on fire
I gotta expect a bigger fire and that
fire to spread right no it's not like
that is not the businesses now you're
adding water you're adding water on top
of an oil fire that just spreads that's
all that does and now everybody's
writing it as my people writing it
anywhere there's protest even here
people do people broker thing overseas
this thing is not just a USA thing it is
not it's not the same thing it's not the
same there's differences but it's not a
u.s. people abusing power that's what it
is people are fed up because they're
abusing power that is not just a USA
thing it's
Minnesota things it's not a George Floyd
thing it's not it's just not one thing
it's spread people are just fed up mmm
now people are just looking at things
and B there's more people that are being
conscious of what's really going on and
that's what that's what's happening it's
no longer the people that are affected
that are all pissed off if the people
that are seeing things that are not
happening and not moving forward now
everybody's pissed off it's just gonna
get and if they keep on not if they keep
on escalating things it's gonna escalate
and it's gonna get worse there's there
there are other steps to this thing
we're not at the worst and I believe
unfortunately I already know I'm a
fatalist hmm I know it's gonna get worse
before it gets better
unfortunately mmm so I think that's
what's going on that's what's happening
it's just a normal course of course
they're riding of course do I agree with
the fact that they're breaking stuff no
but what did you expect you push you
push you push eventually someone's gonna
push back that's what I understand
that's what I get our lift is this thing
I think all of this is normal that
people are doing what they do I don't
agree with everything but I understand
and the thing that happened as well as
that if you're because what's she doing
right now is that you're mad at the
woman because she killed her husband
you're mad at her you're mad at the
woman because she killed her husband but
she didn't look at the husband beating
on her and raping her every day
you see so you I don't necessarily agree
but I understand why she did it
and frankly beer I'm not mad at it yeah
when you go to that's just me when you
go to the police and they say we're not
gonna stop him when your community and
your neighbors don't do anything to stop
the person that's abusing you every day
then yeah at some point you start to go
nuclear you have to understand how the
work you have to you have to understand
how all of this works for Arthur in
order to to something to be done
there has to be something that was done
if I'm able to get up and go to the
police and make a complaint and I'm okay
chances are things are not gonna get
done because I can't so whatever for
something to get done I actually have to
die and even if I die something might
not even happen of course they're gonna
write what you think right you got armed
trained soldiers to go to foreign
countries in our under and a lot of them
are not disciplined enough to wage
conflicts ethically but you expect
untrained civilians who are engaging in
protests so I know how to riot
appropriately does that make sense to me
why are you getting shot sprayed or did
work or fumes does that make sense to
anybody you tripping you guys a trick
and I guess like I told people that you
know this is like the way I described it
but it's like when you get punched and
you don't know how to box your first
reaction is to start swinging
you swing wow you well that's what
you're seeing you mean seeing people
who've been punched who've been kicked
to watch their neighbors get killed
who've watch their siblings we've seen
strangers that look like them died on
camera and nobody moved so they said I'm
gonna engage in my own self defense and
what do they do they start swinging and
that's what I'm seeing right now that's
it
nobody wants to write you think we wake
up and we're just like [ __ ] yeah let's
start burning down no you have to be
pushed to that point so that's pretty
much all I got that's pretty much all
right that's it tell us what you guys
think in the comments
[Music]